so wizard so our joy Khan is going to
act as a magic wand and we are going to
try to thrust a ball of energy to our
opponent to knock them out
do I have to smile like that and we want
to entertain of course our players in
the room so you're basically thrusting
forward yes and if you counter if if you
thrust and I thrust were right after
that I counter and it'll get pushed back
on you so okay you're again it's very
tempting to look at the screen and then
but the less you do the more reason the
better it can be so to to start out
we're going to spin car wands above our
heads to kind of sure I'm not hitting
anything up here be mindful of your
surroundings you'll want to have you
want to have some space in front of ya
each other so we don't like actually
slam each other with our magic wands so
go ahead and spin overhead here it's
gonna count us down
[Music]
I was really fast but I was just
countering every every room I'm that
predictable we've seen well we've seen
some matches go like really back and
forth a long time I've seen something
like yeah that's embarrassing telephone
all right so I guess team captains we
started up here we can play the first
game before each game starts there will
be kind of just a tutorial video we can
watch this here we're actually gonna be
sitting so we can go ahead and set these
joique on just down like that like a
telephone we can pull up these schools
as it rings sometimes it will give you a
specific ring to listen for the phone so
go ahead just pick up real quick there's
no we don't need the strap for this game
so we'll set them set the joy calm down
we're gonna look at each other hands on
your knees we're gonna be the audience
we can hear answer the phone as soon as
it rings hello ants are nice and loud or
something else you could be like now
face each other there's five
yes
[Applause]